hello all and welcome to episode 3 of
the you reviewers Movie Awards the movie
awards show for you by people like you
as Roddy Piper one said I'm back here
with the schmoes and we're down to the
wire for the categories the supporting
actors and actresses that is so [ __ ] is
getting real now introductions have
already been made in the first video so
let's get right to it and for the first
category our presenters are actually the
co-hosts you've seen them for the past
two videos for the you reviewers Movie
Awards I'm not quite sure if they're a
prequel to The Odd Couple or a prequel
to grumpy old men in either case
presenting our first category are the
schmoes best breakthrough performances
well that was a lot of fun our next
presenter is of course oh good know who
you is you're improvising and you don't
know who it is I'm sure it's is somebody
very talented yeah it's not just me no
it's us all right fine oh this one is
breakthrough actress and break your
actor yeah this is the opposite of the
career achievement out then I'm trotting
out some ninety-year-old to grab an
award and go backstage and take their
metamucil no this is a young
up-and-comer who think is going to be
around cinema for a long time and I hope
they let us sleep in their guest house
and I have to tell you it was a
landslide for both of these I will be
presenting the breakthrough actor and
you who's ending the breakthrough
actress thank you want to trust me with
the young girl let's roll the dice God
bright eyes run boy ladies and gentlemen
this year's you reviewers breakthrough
actor is spider-man himself social
network Andrew Garfield
good job Spidey we applaud you and there
were a couple of breakthrough
performances for actor this year
spider-man and kick ass but Garfield
really showed his acting chops in this
movie and he actually made me okay with
the fact that he's going to be
spider-man even though he's like 30
congratulations Garfield now don't suck
ass body or all of my subscribers will
probably kill you that's right Andrew
Garfield quite the guy that kind of got
screwed in the social network he made me
help create Facebook with Mark
Zuckerberg and then he just walks in
this good-looking as Justin Timberlake
on they went on to take really creepy
pictures of spider-man like sticking his
balls in some guy's face what do you see
the new pictures no it's awful oh good
well we'll give the guy a ward and then
beat him up a little bit teabagging is
always welcome here the reviewers awards
I'm trying to save way out of that
creepiness I am going to be presenting
the best breakthrough Actress category
and you know we did there was a lot of
greater emphasis this year I don't know
what you're doing uh those a drumroll
you look like you're having some sort of
see problem yeah if anybody saw this on
True Grit you probably are aware that
the person who I my penny stole the
entire movie was the owner of play
Mattie Ross and that of course is hailee
steinfeld yes
and for the girls as well there were a
couple of hopefuls for this one that
girl from kickass and let me in and
hailee steinfeld I didn't care too much
for let me in but that girl had a good
year but hailee steinfeld let's face it
we're still talking about her she was
that girl that was like a freak you know
she's just like too smart for her own
good I really think she could kick my
ass in math and chess and general
vocabulary definitely spelling now I
hate her now good job steinfeld you
deserve it you cannot see this movie and
not come out and talking about her yeah
I mean she was so good and she hit this
time she speaks better than you and I
ever will ever that's right and again
these are the breakthrough one so for
Haley and for Andrew again when
spider-man with great power comes great
responsibility do good work all right
don't be like Halle Berry when in a war
than golf make Catwoman all right be
yourself make sure yourself i love how
Haley like makes Justin Bieber wait a
little bit before she returns his texts
keep them on a leash that's room yeah
well I and we're on tour next category
best supporting actress because what
would the main actors have if they
didn't have the supporting actors to
bounce their lines off of unless you're
Sam Rockwell and moon you usually need a
supporting crew yeah women in this films
that basically put on such a great
performance and add to you cannot it's
like literally the PIP into the Jordan
very good yeah it's what it is and the
harloff to the Ellis false and here to
give us the winner for Best Supporting
Actress of 2010 is two-time runner-up
for best beard on YouTube Mike from
belated media take it away Best
Supporting Actress
a dedicated Queen eventual cowgirl a
spunky ballerina and two ladies from all
the nominees are Helena Bonham Carter
for the King's Speech you can expect to
see her soon in the final installment of
the Harry Potter series and then after
that a lot of Tim Burton films Hailee
Steinfeld for True Grit as a newcomer
you probably haven't seen any of her
previous works you can be damn sure that
our agent doesn't want her going back to
school milla Kunis for Black Swan you've
heard her is megan family guy and seen
her magazines and been very happy for
that expect to see her in the upcoming
Seth MacFarlane feature Ted starring
Marky Mark Melissa Leo for the fighter
you can look forward to more Leo this
year and Kevin Smith's red state be sure
to catch the tour as it passes through
your city and btdubs I'm a verga and
closing at our nominees is Amy Adams
also for the fighter older folks may
have seen her in doubt younger folks may
have seen her an enchanted will ignore
leap here and you can look forward to
her in the new Muppets movie well so
there was rumor flying around about her
playing miss Frizzle on the new Magic
School Bus movie if anybody knows about
this pleasley details on my channel Oh
Danny tamborelli what happened and the
winner is Hailee Steinfeld for True Grit
congratulations you young thing you
look at that hazy steinfeld winning it
again now a lot of people were pissed
off by the way that she was known that
she was nominated for Best Supporting
and thought she should have a Best
Actress not hey you know what do you
think she was in the movie that she
carried the movie did you know I know
that it was her story I get it I don't
know I'm on the fence about I understand
that i'm having this she did she ended
up winning something instead of just
being nominated yeah thing that she
would have I think you know she would
have one up against Allen Foreman and
that betting on I don't know if she's
gonna be yes yes one she took it she's
the first ever you reviewers Best
Supporting Actress congratulations hi
hailee steinfeld that's right we can
celebrate in five years right alright
schmoes going for the retirement plan
now I actually got to give my two cents
on this I actually do think that hailee
steinfeld should have been up for Best
Actress not supporting actress of 2010
because it was her story it was her
movie Jeff Bridges yeah he was older but
he was a supporting character he helped
her go get Brolin but she stole the show
she had the dialogue she had the story
and she was in it the most best actress
even if she is like 11 however she won
and that makes me happy and our next
category the other end of the coin for
Best Supporting Actress Best Supporting
Actor and as we've all seen in the past
Jack Sparrow heath ledger's joker
supporting actors can take the movie and
just steal it and here to present best
supporting actor is our buddy if you're
a film fan or a film reviewer on YouTube
you've probably interacted with this guy
he's been one of my biggest supporters
ever since I have like 30 subscribers he
was the guy he saw me and he was like
you know what dude I like you you got
something keep it up he was the dude
that made me go you know what maybe I
should do this I call him the mace windu
of YouTube and I've officially talked
about him more than I've talked about
the category and he is theory of the
film fan Curie's one of our bodies he
obviously hit our awesome especially
with us and now he gets to be part of
the real movie awards season would love
the fury is is doing this in fury full
band is one of the one of the first you
to reviewers out there and yeah it's
been so supportive of us he's been great
this guy as a film fan yeah it's in his
title he knows what's going on to New
York dude he breaks it down and he's
going to breaking it down
you with his own type of special
presentation fury of the filmfare best
supporting actor I hope everyone is
enjoying the you reviewer movie awards
now I want to do a little something with
you guys close your eyes go ahead it's
okay close him now imagine the following
films No Country for Old Men inglorious
basterds the dark knight all right now
open your eyes I'm betting that the
following images came up when you
thought of No Country for Old Men
picturing Javier Barden walk around with
that weird hairdo popping people in the
head with that crazy air gun thingy or
christoph waltz has the german assassin
and inglourious basterds or how about
heath ledger in his amazing performance
as the Joker in the Dark Knight all
supporting roles are unforgettable
characters supporting characters have a
tricky role to play while vital to the
overall story they can't outshine main
character but done right a supporting
character not only elevates the main
character but the entire film itself a
great supporting character can turn a
good film into a great film this year's
nominees are Christian Bale in the
fighter Geoffrey Rush In The King's
Speech Andrew Garfield in the social
network Jeremy Renner in the town and
Tom Hardy and inception and the winner
is Christian Bale yes yes Christian Bale
that's what I'm talking about everybody
voted voted right Christian Bale
deserves this win all right good stuff
all right wait wait oh oh this way okay
to nobody surprise bail wins it he
should have wanted he was awesome in it
Thank You fury it was really awesome
they brought that down I agree with you
yeah I mean bail bail was awesome bail
was basically smoking crack he's
incredible what he puts himself through
he loses all the way to play Dicky
Eklund now he's going to put on a bunch
of way to play Batman I can do one of
those two things well put on a Batman
suit in cake happy birthday cakes to
mark Christian Bale man personally I
think he's one of the best actors of our
time because an American Psycho we all
believed the guy would kill you with a
chain saw down a flight of stairs as
Batman we all believe that he was not
hockey past and in the fighter who also
still believe that he was on crack so
hailee steinfeld for two awards Andrew
Garfield and Christian Bale I cannot
look you in the eyes and tell you that
those people were anything less than
amazing in those roles so that's our
show for episode 3 of the year reviewers
movie awards episode for coming tomorrow
on the schmoes channel where we wrap it
up big man we got Best Actor Best
Actress Best Director and Best Picture
and special guest katee sackhoff from
Battlestar Galactica I'm happy about
that genuinely am happy like that i keep
my fanboy ism in so again thank you to
the schmoes for co-hosting with me thank
you all for watching spreading the word
and thank you to all who watch the first
video and left hate comments and are now
back to watch the third video because
that makes no sense to me but I like it
and I thank you for it until next time I
know we are not the most professional
award show I know that but we are fun
alpha and I'll put it to you this way
danielle from jess x TV and Duncan rocks
saw an advanced screening of the you
reviewers Movie Awards three minutes and
46 seconds later this happened anyone
else strangely turned on right now no
seriously you're not i mean come on that
mustache is awesome i mean
you